[Aplausos]
buenas tardes
parece que hacer la primera vez que
habló en público esto
lo hago por ellos dondequiera que estén
algunos se preguntarán por qué la pala
porque el machete
algunos de ustedes tienen un familiar
desaparecido
yo creo que la mayoría de nosotros tiene
un amigo un vecino un familiar
o sabe de alguien que está desaparecido
soy mirna nereida medina quiñones
desde hace cuatro años de medio empezó
una lucha no luce muy triste
una lucha
que alguien puede seguir porque lo haces
el 14 de julio
desapareció mi hijo roberto corrales
medina
mi hijo tenía 21 años
vendía discos y memorias en la
gasolinera en el fuerte cuando es el 14
de julio a las 5 45 de la tarde llegó
una camioneta negra
y se lo llevó
y así es como empezamos
a buscar empecé a buscar a roberto
hicimos un grupo grande nosotros somos
las rastreadores del fuerte
y la restaurado del fuerte tenemos estas
dos preguntas
dónde
dónde están
y por qué
también quiero comentarles que nosotros
no buscamos culpables nosotros solamente
buscamos a nuestros tesoros
disculpar esto esto es algo que me mueve
esto no es un guión esto es algo que a
mí me me sale el corazón y la verdad
cada vez yo decía que cada vez que lo
hablabas era como sacarlo esto y hoy que
he estado conviviendo con todos ustedes
veo que son diferentes cuando vi que la
mayoría de los que estaban aquí eran
jóvenes mismos cuáles son mucho quinto
porque aquí pudiera estar mi hijo y no
está yo estoy aquí
porque no está roberto
pero quiero decirles que nosotros
hacemos esto como tu amor y con mucha
dignidad más que nada
cuando nosotros salimos a buscar
nosotros salimos a buscar con mucha
esperanza y con mucho dolor
alguien dice pero por qué lo hacen si
esto lo deben de hacer las autoridades
créanme que cuando desapareció roberto
yo fui a las autoridades y les pregunté
que si donde buscaban que yo quería
saber que habían hecho para encontrar a
roberto probert a un joven que no fumaba
no tomaban usaba drogas ni vendía drogas
que habían pasado con roberto ellos me
dijeron que lamentablemente ellos no
buscaban
con esa respuesta yo
salí de esa oficina con mucho color y
con mucha tristeza y levante mi vista al
cielo
y le hice una promesa roberto le hizo
una promesa te buscaré hasta encontrarte
y así lo hice
empezamos a trabajar en las redes
sociales a buscar a la semana a la
semana
encontramos una primera fosa con cinco
cuerpos
yo estaba segura que en esos cinco
cuerpos estaba muerto
mostraba
y poco a poco fuimos haciendo difusión
fuimos trabajando y el 12 de septiembre
ya éramos 38 familias
hicimos una primera manifestación en el
fuerte porque nosotros somos
desaparecidos del fuerte ese es nuestro
nombre porque ahí en el fuerte
desapareció roberto al inicio esto
y
cuando yo llegué ante el presidente
municipal y le dije que estaba haciendo
en la manifestación porque había 38
personas desaparecidas en el municipio
el señor me dijo que era una mentirosa
de los planes andaban de vago
y yo le dije que ella estaba en los
expedientes de personas desaparecidas
fue en ese momento cuando el gobierno
empezó a atenderme a hacerme caso
entre comillas
y seguimos hoy en día somos más de 120
mujeres que portamos esto
una pala un machete y salimos a buscar a
nuestros tesoros
cuando nosotros llamamos tesoros muchas
personas pensaban que eran tesoros
pero para nosotros encontrar un dedo una
uña
un pedazo de cráneo una vértebra es un
tesoro
a nosotros nos arrebataron algo tan
querido
nos arrebataron a un hijo o un ser
querido a un hermano al esposo
cuándo
nosotros vamos a la búsqueda o ya somos
un grupo organizado tenemos una oficina
tenemos a búsqueda a miércoles y
domingos cada uno de nosotros va con una
esperanza
de ir a una fosa que tristeza de siglos
por esperanza de una fosa
y encontrar ahí
a un tesoro cuando vamos abrimos los
ojos
encontramos el tesoro
cada uno de nosotros tiene un
sentimiento encontrado porque ahí todos
queremos
que el tesoro que está en la fosa sea
nuestro familiar
y pues no nos damos cuenta qué
que no es
nos da mucho gusto
al principio queremos que sea para saber
para que se nos termine es incertidumbre
de no saber dónde están que tienen lo
que pasó pero cuando te das cuenta que
no es le da gracias a dios porque en el
fondo te queda esa leve esperanza de que
algún día va a llegar te va a tocar la
puerta te va a decir aquí estoy he
regresado
así es como vivimos nosotros hablo de
nosotras
porque es muchas desgraciadamente
vivimos en un estado de mucha
inseguridad en un estado en el que hay
más de 4.000 desaparecidos hablábamos el
año pasado de 3 mil 700 víctimas
desaparecidas y hoy en la fiscalía dice
que sólo hay 4 mil es cierto nosotras
nosotras sabemos que son tres veces más
a nivel nacional se hablaba de 37 mil
hoy la comisión nacional de búsqueda
dice que hay más de 40 mil personas
desaparecidas en el país
yo a veces digo que caminamos sobre
tumbas que nuestro país es una fosa de
gigante igual este tema en este tema
fuera de nosotros estábamos hablando 13
temas diferentes y hoy quiero aprovechar
que están aquí ustedes para hablar de
de la seguridad y del autocuidado
también muchachos es muy importante
perdón porque me salí del tema salir
pero vale la pena
[Aplausos]
a veces el hecho de que la mamá esté
molestando te diga llámame cuando
llegues o avisa que te vas a quedar y
nosotros lo tomamos como algo a mi mamá
te enfadas me sale me aman y que fuera
un niño pero créanme muchachos que para
nosotros que ya lo hemos vivido es tan
triste es tan tan pesado pensar yo tengo
otro hijo pensar que te lo pueden llevar
también imagínense a sus padres cuando
ustedes no llegan cuando ustedes no le
contestan el teléfono cuando ellas no
saben dónde están imagínense la angustia
que sienten
yo siempre tomo este ejemplo de que
cuando vamos al súper llevamos a
nuestros hijos bebés y de repente te
quedas viendo una etiqueta o una
mercancía porque teníamos la atención y
descuidas tienes a tu bebé 7 desaparece
cinco segundos esos cinco segundos se
vuelven angustiosos a una imagínense a
nosotros que tienen que pasar años
y quisiera decirlo pero muchas muchas de
nosotros nunca vamos a saber qué pasó ni
dónde está
yo quiero comentarles que
nosotras las rastreadores cuando uno de
nuestros hijos de nuestros tesoros
cumpleaños de desaparecido cumpleaños
nosotros lo festejamos como si estuviera
y vamos a buscarlos creo que eso lo hace
más digno nuestro trabajo que hacer una
manifestación vale más asociarnos e ir a
buscarlos
el día 14 de julio del 2017
ese día cumplió tres años de
desaparecido roberto
y mis compañeras y yo fuimos a buscar al
fuerte donde él desapareció y trabajamos
desde las 8 de la mañana hasta las tres
de la tarde caminamos tres kilómetros y
no encontramos nada no íbamos a buscar a
roberto claro y vamos a buscar de
repente
una llamada nos dicen no se salgan de
ahí hay un tesoro que no
y yo vi las caras de mis compañeras con
sed con hambre y les dije seguimos y
parece que todas se pusieron de acuerdo
pero si vamos
hicimos nuestro plan de búsqueda subimos
el cerro
y por allá a lo lejos gritan uno de los
señores
aquí es tu cráneo
y cuando se me dijo que esto un gran yo
sentía algo aquí en mi corazón y camine
y estaba a diez metros de la fosa y yo
ya olía van a decir que esto lo que olía
roberto y olía yo dije es roberto me
conforme me iba acercando
yo iba sintiendo luego sintiendo y llegó
la fosa y ahí estaba
su mercancía ahí estaba lo que él vendía
estaba parte de su ropa
ya estaba su cráneo
y las vértebras
y parte de su brazo fue todo lo que
encontré de roberto
pero para mí
fue el tesoro más grande que podría
haber encontrado que había encontrado
amigo
yo le cumplir la promesa roberto pueden
ver
promesa cumplida
[Aplausos]
mis compañeras las rastreadoras y
también compañeros fueron partes muy
importantes y siguen siendo porque
también quiero comentarles que antes de
encontrar a roberto ya habíamos
encontrado 42 más de nuestro grupo y las
42 personas siguen siguen trabajando
siguen buscan eso hace que las otras
señoras las que aún no encuentran tengan
la esperanza de que en algún momento
ellas van a aportar esta hermosa playera
verde
cuando nosotros vamos a las
manifestaciones nosotros vamos vestidas
las que ya encontramos de verde y las
que buscan de blanco
yo les prometí a la mayoría de mis
compañeras en una reunión que un día un
día vamos a tapizar una calle como un
jardín un día vamos a ir todas de verde
porque todas vamos a encontrar a
nuestros tesoros
alguien me decía que si no teníamos
miedo de hacer lo que nosotros decimos
que no porque cuando yo salir a buscar a
roberto yo salí llena de miedo lleno de
coraje y de impotencia
muchas mujeres dicen que nos va a pasar
algo la misma sociedad yo les digo y
esto también es para para hacer un acto
con ustedes para que nos apoyan en ese
sentido
no nos victimicen por favor porque la
mayoría piensa a lo mejor que están
pensando por algo se lo llevaron algo
hicieron
vendían droga usaban droga para nosotros
en el momento en que la madre de la
familia cruza la puerta a hacer su
denuncia oa pedir el apoyo dejan de ser
todo lo que eran y pasan a ser un tesoro
que localizar yo les pido a ustedes o
alguien cuando alguien les diga por algo
se llevaron a los muchachos que piensen
no todos no todos andaban mal
y a nosotros a cualquiera de nosotros
nos puede pasar por eso es que yo les
hablo de autocuidado cuidémonos mucho a
veces el hecho de que diga esa y puedo
llegar a la una de la mañana anoche a
una chica hija de una de mis compañeras
un taxi un über
le iba diciendo no te da miedo no tengas
miedo porque lo super nativa miedo y van
llegando a dar vuelta para su casa y el
taxi se va de paso
no la dejan
a domicilio
y ella le dice mi mamá es reportera y
desde que empezaste a decir cosas yo le
avisé y ahorita debe andar las patrullas
con la policía buscando
se baja del carro imagínense ustedes
jovencitas ella es una chica que subió
en una universidad muy bonita
tienen que tener mucho cuidado mandar
ubicaciones donde están hacer una
llamada a alguien de confianza si le
sabes que si te habla mi mamá dile que
estoy bien que no pasa nada porque
créanme que
tan solo pensar que alguien se puede
llevar un pedazo de uno
es la muerte nosotros la rastreo del
fuerte no vivimos sobrevivimos creo que
a mi rubero mucho tiempo la verdad
quiero darle las gracias qué bueno que
me tocó lo que ha sido lo último porque
vi como mis compañeros
daban aquí todo lo de ustedes y yo y yo
me pone a llorar yo le hice la promesa a
roberto que no te va a llorar pero es
imposible estos sentimientos te ganen y
la verdad
quiero darle las gracias a todos y
quiero decirles que se cuiden
que se cuiden por favor
y gracias o invitados